where are we at at the moment in
extension two we have been looking
in the 3d coordinate system trying to
understand
geometry and uh and reasoning within
that's what we most recently looked at
on friday's lesson
and using the new tools at our disposal
dot products and projection all the rest
to do that right
um we're gonna continue in that same
vein but
it's gonna feel like we're going to
momentarily take a step backwards to
something which looks
much simpler of lines so here's where i
would like us to begin
in the 2d space not on the 3d space in
the 2d space
lines equations of lines are really
really easy
for example join this down with me right
it's actually very important if you were
to consider something
like x plus y equals one
this is um in fact i'm going to let's go
x plus 2y you'll see why in a second
x plus 2y doesn't seem like it makes so
much of a difference but
x was two y equals one this is a
straight line you could probably tell me
a few things
about it as well if you if i ask you to
graph it i don't need to because i think
you understand it enough
the really important thing i need you to
understand because it's gonna
give a surprising conclusion or
surprising result in 3d
is why why is it that this equation
gives us a line like you've known this
for so long
you've probably not recently or maybe
even ever thought about
it gives you a line but why does it give
you a line
let me try and unpack this for you right
and you can just down with me right
if for example i took some value of
x i don't know like x equals zero
right and i substitute it in what would
happen to y
there would be one value for it right in
this case i guess it would be
a half right and there's nothing else
that y could be
if x equals 0 that tells you that y
equals
a half no ifs or buts right if i try
another x value you can just start with
me like say x equals 1.
then what you would get is that or one
here one here they cancel
so in this case y would be
zero thank you i know it's the end of
the day we can do this we're extension
two okay
so my point here is as you keep on
putting in new
x values you get this very specific y
value out
and if i were to just keep on doing this
forever right every x value gives you
another point
every x value gives you another point
and a collection of points if i did this
forever a collection of points is indeed
a
line and that's what we're after but
if we were to try and say because we've
done this a lot in this topic and quite
successfully a lot of the time
if we were to say like doing with dot
product it's like ah stuff that works in
2d
let's just see if it works in 3d and
sometimes it's great
with some modification what would happen
if we tried to say
extend this into 3d i obviously need
like a third variable there
and it could be any i've arbitrarily
chosen coefficients how about something
like this
right i just chucked a zen in there
right would this give us straight
line now if you have successfully opened
up
3d geogebra go ahead in the top left
hand corner
and just type in this as it say as it
says right x
plus two y minus z equals one
this actual thing
something like that well let's see if
it's
still going to go somewhere interesting
okay um did you did you grab something
did you get it hands up if you've got
something
there hands up one two three four great
thank you hands down okay well done
let me ask a simple question first did
you get a line
no no how disappointing we got a
plane out of this and you can of course
spin it around and you can see from
different angles right
now i'm going to ask you this is why i
said why does this give you a line
right the question you should ask of
this is exactly the same
why does this give us a plane
and we can see the answer if we just try
the same thing that we did
before watch right let's just give this
a go here's my x right
what if i tried putting in something
like x equals zero
what results do i get for now i have to
consider not just y i have to consider
z as well right so i would get 2y
minus z equals 1. now not a rhetorical
question
how many solutions are there to this
equation for y and z
there's an infinite number of solutions
in fact
not just an infinite number of solutions
i have just look at this for a second
and compare it with the first thing that
i wrote here isn't this an infinite
set of solutions in a straight line do
you agree
yeah does that make sense so here you
try one x value and you get a point
but here you try an x value and you get
a line
and then if you have the audacity to try
again
right then you get well in this case um
the one and the one will cancel
so you get two y minus z equals zero
you get another line now
a set of points a collection of points
gives you a line
but a set of lines a collection of lines
gives you a
plane which you are now looking at does
that make sense
um and these these here are all kind of
these lines are in a line
as it were so it's just they're all just
perfectly lined up together which gives
you that plane that you can see there
okay so we need another way to do this
these sort of i guess you could call
them like cartesian equations right
they're not going to cut it right they
don't give us equations of lines
if only we had some kind of object that
was better
at representing things in a 3d space
that we could manipulate instead of just
these
cartesian coordinates oh wait
what was the name of this topic again it
was 3d
vectors what if
what if we actually had vectors
in our equation how would this work
so underneath where you've written this
what i'd like you to do is just draw for
me
a uh we're gonna draw it in 2d because
we have 2d pieces to play but just draw
a cartesian plane for me
okay um what i'm going to show you here
i want in the back of your minds
um the argument that what i'm about to
do unlike here
it can extend into 3d and i want to see
if you can work out why
so let's have two orthogonal axes here
okay and uh what i'm going to do is i'm
going to place say a point like
this up here we'll call this capital a
and then i'm going to have another point
here and we'll call it capital
b okay now if i've got this a and this b
set up what i want to try and understand
is how could i use
vectors to help me articulate and
express
what is the equation of the line that
passes through these
two points okay that's what i'm trying
to get what is the equation of a b
and of course it's going to go forever
because it's a line not an interval or
anything like that
so guess what i'm trying to find is the
equation of this line
here that's what i'm after okay
how do i use vectors to help me here
well we recall that in two dimensions
kind of the way we did this was we
crafted an equation that would
if you put one thing in you'll get
exactly one thing out
one thing in one thing out because then
you've got a set of points
a set of points how could i use
vectors to articulate or describe this
infinite set of points
well just as an example if i where did
my black one get hurt
if i knew what this vector o a
was this vector o
a let's call it say u
i knew what that vector was from the
origin up to a right
and then if i also knew what this vector
was here from
a to b let's call this
v right you can immediately tell me in
terms of vectors
uh at least two points that lie on this
line
a b i mean those two points are a and b
right how would you articulate them in
vector terms
how do we get to a well okay so i've got
u
u plus v that's one of them that's
that's that's gets me to point b
which is on the line how do i get to
point a it's even simpler
it's just you right so these two
are on the line can someone give me in
terms of vectors
another point that's on the line yeah
just give me one
minus v u minus v okay where is this
u minus v well if that's v then minus v
is in the opposite direction
so it's i guess it's somewhere up here
is that okay so you'd get that point
there and sure enough
it's on the line give me another one
brent u plus 2b that'll do it
right u plus 2v you do u and then i
guess you go v
and then you go another v right in fact
you can do any multiple you don't even
need to stick to
whole number integer multiples of v i
could do u plus
half of v where would that be u plus
half of v is an important point actually
it's the midpoint of a and b right so
there right there that's u
u plus half v and you plus one and a
half v
and u plus a million v pi v ev whatever
you want okay
uh we better be careful with our letters
because we'll get confused can i
capture all of these in a single
equation the answer is of course i can
right look at what's
similar or what stays the same and look
at what changes tell me
what stays the same you
that's always the same at the front
right there is always a v
but then the v kind of changes because
i've got
i've got i've got a constant multiple of
v so we just need to say well it's
multiplied by some number of these
now the customary pronumeral that we use
here is a greek letter
lambda right here okay
so lambda if there are any first person
shooter
fans in the room it's that symbol that
the game half-life is based on sorry
i'm just showing my age now but anyway
okay that's why i like lambdas anyway so
this here this is the equation of a line
again customarily we would describe it
as r
it's just kind of the conventional name
for the equation of a line
and importantly it is not just an
equation of a line it's a
vector equation of a line because
it uses vectors to explain what's going
on okay